Firmly entrenched in American society, the
seemingly capricious nature of the Fahrenheit
temperature scale could lead one to think
that its Dutch inventor, Daniel Fahrenheit,
pulled the number for the freezing point (32°F)
of water out of his hat.
But, in fact, its designation, as well as
that of 0°F were precisely (for the early
18th century) calculated based upon deliberate
choices about how to establish fixed points
of temperature.
Engineer, physicist and glass blower, Fahrenheit
(1686-1736) decided to create a temperature
scale based upon three fixed temperature points
– that of freezing water, human body temperature,
and the coldest point that he could repeatably
cool a solution of water, ice and a kind of
salt, ammonium chloride.
It is generally thought he chose these three
points based on an older temperature scale
created by Ole Christensen Rømer (1644-1710)
20 years earlier.
Under Rømer’s system, brine (the salt-/ice-
water mixture) freezes at 0°, water at 7.5°,
normal human body temperature was 22.5° and
water’s boiling point was 60°.
Desiring to make calculations easier (i.e.,
produce fewer fractions), and to increase
the precision of the scale by increasing the
number of distinguishable parts within it
(granularity), Fahrenheit decided to multiply
each value by a factor of about 4, and set
to work.
According to his published article on the
subject, he started with the brine and a blank
thermometer; he then assigned the point where
the thermometer was the lowest as 0°F. Next,
he placed the thermometer in still water just
as ice was beginning to form, and eventually
assigned this 32°F. He then measured human
body temperature and assigned this 96°F.
He ultimately chose these two numbers, as
opposed to 30°F (7.5*4) and 90°F (22.5*4)
in no small part due to the fact that the
64 degrees between the two points made marking
lines on the thermometer easier (due to the
six equal intervals).
As water (at sea level and standard atmospheric
pressure) boils at about 212°F in the original
scale, 180° above its freezing point, this
number was eventually defined as the scale’s
exact boiling point of water.
This more precise definition ultimately forced
a slight adjustment of normal body temperature
to about 98°F from 96°F. (Of course, “normal”
body temperature is a bit of a misnomer here,
with it varying from person to person, and
even varying quite a bit in an individual
based on a variety of factors such as time
of day, age, etc., commonly ranging between
about 97°F and 99°F.)
ThermometerAs for the Celsius temperature
scale, it has been around for almost as long
as Fahrenheit, but it wasn’t nearly as widely
used as today until the conversion of most
of the world to the metric system in the 1960s
and 1970s.
Anders Celsius (1701-1744) was also a physicist,
as well as an astronomer and mathematician.
Interested in atmospheric sciences, in 1742
Celsius published his finding that the freezing
point of water was independent of latitude
(something previously debated); he also developed
a consistent method of calculating the boiling
point of water as barometric pressure changes.
To accommodate his findings, bring even more
rationality to measuring temperature, and
avoid negative numbers, Celsius designed his
own temperature scale, and assigned 100°C
as the freezing point of water and 0°C as
its boiling point at sea level (and no, that’s
not a typo).
Celsius’ colleague from Uppsala University,
Carl Linnaeus (of the famous taxonomy) is
reputed to be responsible for reversing the
numbers.
Specifically, in the 1730s, Linnaeus built
an orangery (a kind of conservatory originally
erected to grow citrus fruits) in Uppsala.
In order to maintain the proper temperature
for his exotic plants, he needed an accurate
thermometer, which he ordered from the Swedish
instrument maker, Daniel Ekström.
It was delivered in December of 1745, and
in a contemporaneous publication, Linnaeus
noted that “our thermometer shows 0 (zero)
at the point where water freezes and 100 degrees
at the boiling-point of water.”
As this is the earliest record of having switched
the degrees to the modern form, Linnaeus is
often given credit for the idea.
Up until the latter half of the 20th century,
it was much more common to say “centigrade”
rather than “Celsius,” with centigrade
deriving from the Latin “centum” (100)
and “gradus” (steps)- “100 steps.”
This officially switched in 1948 partially
due to confusion between many other uses of
“centigrade” in various languages, such
as French where it is used as a name for a
unit of angular measurement.
However, many did not immediately switch to
using “Celsius” right away.
For instance, the BBC continued to use “centigrade”
all the way up into the mid-1980s on their
weather reports, before finally relenting
and going with Celsius.